well for one thing the creation of the
object and adding a local property seems
like something we could do up in the car
constructor where we used to have object
creation we can simply call the car
function now and it will produce an
object that can act as the starting
point for the rest of the subclass
technically we have a working super
class at this point but there's still
more repeated code that we should be
able to move into it let's take the code
for the addition of a move method out of
those sub class constructors and move it
up here into the superclass constructor
at this point we have to complete
subclass functions and one superclass
constructor function that creates a bit
of a starting point for each of those
subclasses to build on top of